what are your thoughts on using peptides? Not ozemic and all those ones. Some combinations I've
looked at for perimenopause and this person lists five different peptides for perimenopause.
Out of these right here, the only one that I would say that I would approve is the BPC 157 and the
thymosin beta-4. The other ones are meant to stimulate an increased metabolic rate.
You would not want to do that for cancer. There are certain peptides that if you're trying
to increase metabolic rate, which can increase like the Tessa Borland helps with visceral fat
loss, well, it does so by increasing metabolic rate. Well, you don't want to increase metabolic
rate with a person with cancer. Now, let's say a person I don't have cancer anymore. Can I start
taking these? Yes, you just have to be careful with some of these. There's not a decade's worth
of studies on what this does to the human body. That's the only thing that I would caution you
about it. I've read multiple books on peptide therapy. I know several of my friends and our
practitioners that are doing peptide therapy. It shows some promise. It makes some physiological sense,
but it also you just don't know what you're messing with. I personally would be cautious about it
and go slow with anything that I would do because there could be some reports of some negative effects
of those things. I would just be careful about it.